but we've had a few people reach out to
us and say that they watched your video
on you know sort of what it takes to be
an actor moving to LA and that that
video was part of the catalyst that got
hit them here you feel any kind of
responsibility any kind of joy and
knowing that you inspired people enough
to leave their family and friends and
the safety of where they grew up maybe
maybe not come on you I do feel
responsibility because of the film
courage videos because I have heard from
people and I actually met a guy on the
street I was in an event in front of the
Egyptian he said hey you're that guy I
came to LA after I watched your video
Wow and you really did but I told you
not to come I said don't do this and you
did it you did it anyway yes it's it's
it's great and people were right in the
last advice and I'll say look I don't
know anything we only know what works
for us in this business we don't really
know nobody really knows anything but
yeah I'm happy to tell you what little i
dunno right so then going back to the
red carpet event the one where you
weren't on the list where you caught
yourself in a moment where you said
matter is dead baby where you caught
yourself in a moment saying I don't like
that I'm not on this list and then in
the same moment I don't like myself for
not liking the fact that I'm on this
list and some enzyme een don't you think
that that was almost needed because then
look something new came out of it and
that is you decided if I'm going to do
this it's going to be for roles that I
really feel a strong connection to not
something where they want to see the
monkey dance with more numbers yeah not
being on the list and be turned away in
front of people that you know is a good
thing it's a good thing because the way
that you react to it will show you how
addicted you were becoming to celebrity
and when that happened to me and I was
supposed to be on the list and there
were people there with me who were on
the list and I was really embarrassed
and I was very pissed and I'm ashamed to
say that I took it out on the person who
had the list who had nothing to do with
it with who was in the Lister wasn't but
he really made me think it really made
me think because I was outside that
event looking in at all of the people
but I was in the same world you know the
birds sing on my side too but you forget
all of that when you're not on the list
you